hello everyone I'm standing here I'm
sitting here in the Garden of Gethsemane
to look just next to me this is It's
reputedly the stone where Christ prayed
and wept when he came up to the garden
um it's really amazing place it's
reputed that some of the trees in the
garden might be 2 000 years old it'll be
some of the shoots of shoots might be
from the time of Christ
and the garden here is very interesting
for many reasons it can really help us
understand the way that the story of
Christ is told and the way that the
symbolism in his story functions as the
story of the garden is really
a little version of a return to the
Garden of Eden and it's also a little
version of what will happen later in the
crucifixion
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
welcome to the symbolic world
[Applause]
[Music]
they went to a place called Gethsemane
and Jesus said to his disciples sit here
while I pray he took Peter James and
John along with him and he began to be
deeply distressed and troubled my soul
is overwhelmed with sorrow to the point
of death he said to them stay here and
keep watch
going a little farther he fell to the
ground and prayed that if possible the
hour might pass from him Abba Father he
said everything is possible for you take
this cup from me yet not what I will but
what you will
then he returned to his disciples and
found them sleeping Simon he said to
Peter are you asleep couldn't you watch
keep watch for one hour Watch and Pray
so that you will not fall into
temptation
spirit is willing but the flesh is weak
once more he went away and prayed the
same thing when he came back he again
found them sleeping because their eyes
were heavy they did not know what to say
to him
returning the third time he said to them
are you sleeping and resting enough the
hour has come look the son of man is
delivered into the hands of sinners rise
let us go here comes my betrayer
just as he was speaking Judas one of the
twelve appeared with him was a crowd
armed with swords and clubs sent from
the chief priests the teachers of the
law and the elders
now the betrayer had arranged a signal
with them
the one I kiss is the man arrest him and
lead him away under guard
going at once to Jesus Judas said Rabbi
and kissed him the man sees Jesus and
arrested him then one of those standing
near drew his sword and struck the
servant of the high priest cutting off
his ear
am I leading a rebellion to Jesus that
you have come out with swords and clubs
to capture me every day I was with you
teaching in the temple courts and you
did not arrest me
but the scriptures must be fulfilled
then everyone deserted him and fled
a young man wearing nothing but a linen
garment was following Jesus When They
seized him he fled naked leaving His
Garment behind
coming out he went to the Mount of
Olives as he was accustomed and his
discipled zossel followed him
when he came to the place he said to
them pray that you may not enter into
temptation
he was withdrawn from them about a
stone's throw and he knelt down and
prayed saying father if it is your will
take this cup away from me nevertheless
not my will but yours be done
then an angel appeared to him from
Heaven strengthening him and being an
Agony he prayed more earnestly and his
sweat became like great drops of blood
falling down to the ground
so if you look at the way the story
develops you'll notice that Christ
leaves his disciples and takes with him
three disciples Peter James and John
with him in order to go up the mountain
because the god of Gethsemane is in the
Mount of Olives and so it's up a
mountain it's not at the top of the
mouth but it is up a mountain
and so he leaves his disciples and then
he moves up with the three of them
and then he leaves the three of them at
some place and he goes even further up
into the hill into the garden to pray
so already you can realize what's going
on he's moving from the quantity
to the Quality he's doing the same thing
that Moses did
at Mount Sinai which is leave Israel
down below go up with a few elders and
then leave those Elders in order to find
himself alone at the top of the mountain
in the end
so Christ follows this pattern and as he
goes up he goes into a garden
and this guardian of course is a
stand-in for the Garden of Eden but what
happens in the garden is
very interesting because it plays with
the story of the Garden of Eden
with Adam and Eve but here the return to
a garden is really a return to the
garden with the willingness
facing whether or not he's willing to
die to take the cup to drink the cup to
drink the fruit and die
and so he's not doing it out of his own
will and that's why the story looks the
way that it does he goes and he asks
that this not be done to him if that's
possible because he's not doing it in
order to manifest his unwell but really
to manifest the will of God and to
submit himself to the will of God
and so he comes up to the to the
mountain and he prays that this could be
avoided him
and another little tiny aspect that you
see is that when Christ is praying
he is so anxious that he sweats blood
this is of course a little hint or a
little version of what will then happen
on the cross when blood and water are
coming out of his side
um it's like a little virgin
of what will later happen at the
crucifixion but it's also there to help
us understand the crucifixion because of
course the crucifixion doesn't happen in
a garden but it does happen in a mound
and it's there to connect the stories
together so that we understand how it is
that all these stories are
little versions of the great story and
how it's manifesting to us what it is
ultimately that will happen at the
crucifixion
and so what's interesting in the story
of the garden is that when he goes to
pray
he tells the disciples to stay awake to
remember
not to fall asleep of course you know
that sleep is a stand-in for death it's
a little death so he's saying stay alive
stay awake stay connected to my
attention in the garden
Christ goes up to the garden and then
gives his attention to God and tells the
disciples where lure down to stay
connected to him even though they're
further away from the center from the
top they have to remain awake and
remember but they fall asleep they fall
into death this is of course if you
think of the hierarchy itself you can
understand that this is very much the
image of the death that comes in at the
bottom of the mountain
you know leaving the garden
and so
Christ
so Christ prays that this may be taken
away from him and then he goes back down
three times in order to see and finds
his disciples sleeping not connected not
remembering what is at the top happening
at the top of the mountain of course
this is a little version of the golden
calf what happens at the bottom of the
mountain when Moses goes up to receive
the law
um to show this idea that what happens
when the top and the bottom of the
mountain are disconnected
so as the disciples for the last time
when he comes back on the third time he
realizes that the disciples have
forgotten that they felt fallen asleep
that they haven't been connected their
attention hasn't been connected to the
top of the mountain then the moment of
the Betrayal comes and so Judas comes
and kisses him and that scatters the
disciples it's very important to
understand the scattering it's like the
Betrayal brings about the breakdown the
breaking of the cohesion of the body and
that is of course another image of death
itself so the disciples scattered and
one of the other things that happens is
one of the one of the people following
him someone grabbed his clothing and he
runs away naked so it's an interesting
play on the story of the Garden of Eden
because here as the things scatter
what's happening is not that he's being
clothed like Adam and you were clothed
but that his clothe is being removed and
he's and his nakedness is a nakedness of
shame that he's exposing his cowardice
and the fact that the disciples were not
able to stay connected to Christ so all
the elements in the story of the garden
really are a connection to
the story that happened in the Garden of
Eden also that happened to Moses as he
went up the mountain all of these things
connected together little versions of
What will ultimately happen at the cross
because there is also a story of the
Garment at the cross where Christ's
garment is is cast by Lots where Christ
is his clothing is removed and all he
smashes all those images together of
course on the cross we're not the naked
disciple that ran away is brought onto
the cross itself onto this pillar of the
world where all the elements you know
the cup that he wanted to that he told
Christ God to remove from him is given
to him on the cross as the bitter
vinegar before he dies
um and of course his body is pierced
just as he sweat his sweat blood during
his Moment In the Garden so we can see
how there's this reflection happening
across the stories and how the
crucifixion ends up bringing
all the elements together and so I hope
this was a nice little meditation on on
this this moment in the garden I'm gonna
hopefully I can do a few more videos on
different aspects of Jerusalem and how
they bring the story
how we can understand the story of
Christ by medicating on a few of these
aspects and so thanks everybody see you
soon